welcome to Larry King now our special
guest is Gary Vaynerchuk the
self-proclaimed hustler is a digital
media mogul off the web show host
and venture capitalist among many other
things as the CEO and co-founder of
vaynermedia Gary hosts the hugely
popular YouTube show askgaryvee and is
pen 3 New York Times bestselling books
gary has been named to Fortune
magazine's 40 under 40 list of the most
influential business leaders and holds
the number one ranking on Forbes top 40
social selling market masters his newest
book ask Gary Vee is available now how
did this all start you whine what
happened with you uh what happened with
me is I had the great benefit of being
an immigrant I was born in Belarus in
the former Soviet Union my mother was
from Belarus I didn't know that Minsk
Iping yeah I was born 40 minutes from
minks and came to the States in 78 when
they let some Jews out of there and we
set up in Queens and my parents lived
the American dream they worked very hard
my dad was a stock boy in a liquor store
in Clark New Jersey and eventually
became the manager of that store and
eventually saved up enough money to buy
a store in Springfield New Jersey I was
lemonade stands baseball cards real
hustler kid blow pops anything to make a
buck and at 14 I got dragged into the
store you know oldest son immigrant
family I always tell people Larry that I
lived their grandparents life more than
theirs right couple generations behind
most I did in the 70s and 80s and 90s
when most people did in the 30s 40s and
50s um your legal immigrant I am thank
God okay otherwise I'll probably wind
all show and I fell in love with people
collecting wine when I was 17 because I
was into collecting sports cards that
was my connection point I wanted
collecting I wanted to build 4,000 wine
shops that was I was gonna build a
Toys'R'Us of wine sell the franchise buy
the New York Jets that's what the plan
was heard the internet my freshman year
of college heard that sound
Kukoc knew that it was special and in
1996 I launched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses in America
called winelibrary.com took over my
dad's business kind of running at day to
day in 1998 alongside with him and from
98 to 2003 helped grow that business
from a three to a sixty million dollar
business that became the foundation
built that on e-commerce email marketing
banner advertising Google AdWords things
that the marketing world didn't believe
yet and then YouTube came out and I
started a wine show four months after
YouTube started and not not a wine
expert I grew up a wine expert
you know from from 15 to 30 in those 15
years my whole life was wine were you
always successful in everything but
school didn't do well in school
poor terrible actually punted it you
know it was funny and this is where I
give my parents enormous credit and I
you know it's funny it's a business book
that's his self-awareness my parents
grew up and I give them so much credit
in a world where all their
contemporaries and you know this
education is the way out for immigrants
my mom recognized that I was a merchant
an entrepreneur a promoter at school
failure you failed school school failed
me schools failing entrepreneurs every
single day I was because it's not built
for entrepreneurship it's built for
workers you know if you're being taught
to play within the lines and there's
nothing being taught that maps to the
entrepreneurial market as a matter of
fact my biggest cynicism when I sit
across an entrepreneur today is if they
are too successful at school I probably
look at Ivy League grad starting
startups right now with more of a
negative light than I do somebody who
wasn't as good because what I've learned
over the last five to seven years and by
the way in the last two or three years
I've taken a step back on this because
there's too many entrepreneurial friends
who've gone to great schools that have
been successful so this is not a blanket
statement but I will tell you that in a
world of private schools in a world of
mommy and daddy having a lot of
connections that when you go from 12 15
18 years of that ecosystem and you go
into a market and you create an app the
market
doesn't give a crap who your dad is the
market responds to your product and a
lot of these kids have not been able to
take the punch in the mouth that comes
along with entrepreneurship you're a big
on self-awareness right huge how does
one get to be self-aware I don't know
so how do you teach it I don't know but
I know it's damn important and so I know
where I start and where I stop Larry and
I wish
honestly I'm curious to see over the
next 40 50 years of my career if I
figure it out I think that the things
that I've been pushing people to do is
one create an ecosystem where you make
the people closest to you feel
comfortable to tell you the truth so one
of the things I've been asking for
people to do is tell your mom and dad
and spouse best friend co-worker hey
tell me the truth what am I good at what
am i bad at and spend a month or two to
get them comfortable to actually tell
you the truth because the people that
love you sure don't want to tell you how
did the website thing come about way
back when I mean you your website or the
web shows thing you do is your web show
the biggest thing I do right now is I
run a 650 person social media digital
agency that works with the brands like
Toyota that's collapsing that's called
vaynermedia what is vaynermedia dude
we're a modern-day Mad Men we're a
Madison Avenue agency the same people
that used to sell commercial time on
anything you ever did in radio and
television we now do that on Facebook
snapchat Instagram and we produce the
creative for the brand's to sell stuff
through the phone because Larry and I'd
love to get I almost want to I know
we're doing a show here but I'd love to
get your thoughts maybe after maybe
right now who knows I think we're living
through a very interesting moment I
believe that the telephone is becoming
the television and the television is
becoming the radio and I've been
spending a lot of time studying the
transition in the late 50s from radio to
television because this is the first
time we've had a platform shift in our
society in a half a century and I think
it's a very big deal and I've been
spending an enormous amount of time last
five years trying to be the best
storyteller for that platform next
utilizing the digital world for your
entrepreneurial benefit how social media
can transform your business
stay with us we'll be back with the
incredible Gary Vaynerchuk so did you
wish named you know it's funny I know it
always confuses people people don't
think it but I am good book askgaryvee
is out now on entrepreneur on
entrepreneurs take on leadership social
media and self-awareness okay how do we
use social media to help our business
well I think we first understand that
social media is a slang term for the
current state of the internet and when
you position social media that way you
take it a lot more seriously so step one
Larry for 97% of the people that are
watching is to actually take it serious
that's number one again we were talking
as we were getting ready a lot of radio
people didn't take television serious
when the transition happened that was
their loss correct right that's what's
happening right now Larry this is
historic the history always tells you
the future and so that's what's
happening so first take it serious to
understand that Facebook and Instagram
and snapchat and YouTube these are
different channels it's the difference
between CNN and Fox and ABC and sports
ESPN you've got to understand the
context of the medium that you're on so
when you're storytelling about your
business on YouTube you've got to
produce different content than when
you're putting a picture on Facebook
so again sitting in your presence I
almost want to ask questions more than
do this interview I think that people
underestimate context of the medium
right I would assume that when you
interviewed somebody on radio versus
when you did on television there's
slight differences because they're
different mediums like slight and it's
slight but it's real and in that
slightness is all the magic number three
it's understanding that you have to
provide value to many businesses right
now on Facebook and Twitter and
Instagram every post they put out is buy
my stuff buy my stuff buy my stuff
here's where I'm gonna be check me out
buy my book check out my experience
watch me on my show and nobody's
providing value so the prior book I
wrote to this was called Jab Jab Jab
right hook give give give ask and it
gave people a formula of how to put out
content that actually gave people enough
value that you then had them in a
consideration to buy your stuff
the technology changes so much that
something could be new tomorrow that
wipes out what was yesterday right tough
crap right the market is the market is
the market every day people put out
shows on radio and television that tried
to knock you off your pedestal you had
to become number one stay number one
that's the market I wish that Twitter
wasn't losing its leadership role
I have 1.2 million followers on Twitter
I built my brand on Twitter I'm dominant
on Twitter I have 2.8 well because your
legend is good wise Twitter because
because Twitter lost its way in my
opinion because they didn't create an
algorithm and everybody who follows
everybody sees everything and it gets
too loud and so they had what I call a
firehose problem too much information
meant that people tuned it out and so
what Facebook did and what Instagram
does is they don't show you everything
they show you the stuff based on what
you've been liking that it thinks that
you're gonna like all this yes most
appealing to the young right if you're
over 40 I into this if you're over 50 I
think so I think if you look at behavior
let me ask you a question have you
noticed some of you're over 40 over 50
friends start to send emojis on texts I
don't know what it is do you know the
little poop pictures and a little face
and a smile some text well listen let's
turn off the cameras we got things to do
here I need Larry to sudden some poop
emojis immediately poop emoji yes poop
emoji is the next thing that I got doing
the next in the next segment we're going
to talk coop emojis
but I look I think if you look at the
data it's stunning what's happened 35 to
60 I'll go a different route with you it
for anybody who's watching right now if
you're lucky enough to know your parent
at the age that you are now if you're at
an age where you actually knew your mom
and dad at the same age you are now you
will notice that your behavior is much
younger much younger that has a lot to
do with technology technology's dragging
people we're living through a youth of
vacation of our society the
fastest-growing segment on the
instagrams and the snapchats of the
world are the 40 Andover's because just
like Facebook these things a jump Wow
yeah now explain all of this with regard
to the New York Jets I desperately want
to buy them Larry
you do yes I do can you afford it not
yet but I've never felt more in control
of that actually happening than I do
right now why this you're so
level-headed yes I love things yes what
sports things are a fan thing yes they
are at short for fanatic yes it is
that's emotional yeah listen I'm a
flawed human I mean we all have our
shortcomings so you know look I'll tell
you the truth when I came to America in
in Queens and in Dover I couldn't speak
English Dover New Jersey's folks and
they brew no I wasn't speaking Yiddish
but I was being Russian um but there was
something when I moved to at us in New
Jersey the kid Erik Godfrey Robbie
Turner they were playing football and
they made me a Jets fan and it was my
first kite it was my first American
thing and my mom everybody had a Jets
Jersey and I wanted one and my mom we
couldn't afford stuff like that it's not
what immigrants do you don't go out and
buy a $30 Jets Jersey so my mom knitted
me one and so I have it it's my prized
possession it's literally my prized
possession and I've created a fairy tale
in my mind somewhere around second or
third grade that I was going to go from
not being able to afford a Jersey to
owning the whole damn thing and that is
the the quest to buy the Jets is my
happiness whether I buy them or not so
many variable that Woody Johnson doesn't
sell well he'll be dead but it oh that's
right I mean there's an advantage of
being 25 to 30 years younger than the
current owner but you don't know
anything can happen right and so there's
a lot of things I can't control in that
fairytale but I can control the
ambitious climb to get there you are so
on top of things does a jet loss affect
you yes the Jets are my one kryptonite
I'm actually stunningly level-headed I'm
basically unemotional when it comes to
business I could tell I you know it's a
win-loss thing it's a net-net game I can
deal yes the Jets bother me it's it
because I'm not in control quite a few
questions on my blog regarding tips for
jump starting a business what are the
three most important things to keep in
mind when starting up one that caches
oxygen I'm blown away by all these
people that are starting businesses that
don't realize that money is important
like they think about all these things
they're trying to think about four years
from now and they haven't made their
first check just complete lack of
practicality when thinking about a
business number two strengths are your
salesmen are you the accountant are you
doing a financial strength you have
sales strength are you operationally are
you good at HR whatever you're best at
do that surround yourself with the other
three or four pillars that need to have
a business and number three look for the
white space meaning where are people not
marketing and storytelling that you can
is snapchat is YouTube is a blog or a
podcast your way to separate yourself
from everybody else while they're
running Direct Mail or radio or
television or print advertising what's
the white space in your sector that
nobody else is filling okay well the
game view only new I just so cool what's
the last piece of advice you ever got
that when I was 14 I was full of crap I
was a Salesman I would say anything to
you to make you buy my baseball cards or
a bottle of wine my dad grabbed me by
the neck and he said listen to me where
we come from you've got one thing your
word and that one moment easily my mom
did most of the work my mom did most of
the work my dad was at work I never saw
my damn toes 14 she built a self-esteem
she made me the right kind of guy kind
she built the foundation but that one
tweak by my dad change the outcome of my
life from being a good huckster salesman
who would have made it okay and made a
good buck to having real potential you
get some bad advice - I don't really
listen to Vice at all so I'm sure I get
better Larry I actually think I get bad
advice every day is there a company we
should be paying more attention to music
dot Lee it's the emerging thing
snapchats the one for most people but
I'm making that assumption that as
people continue to watch this they'll
know about that music dot ly is the
emerging social network with junior high
kids in America and China it has a
chance your biggest failure and what you
learn from it I think my biggest failure
was when I transitioned from day to day
in the wine business to starting
vaynermedia I wrote a book called crush
yet that became a big New York Times
list I started three
other businesses I was the cut I was
like a guy that came out of a long
relationship and wanted to date
everything I learned that even though my
brain tells me I can do everything
because I worked 15 to 18 hours a day I
can't and you only have so much energy
and focus and I need to cut that in what
industry is on the verge of exploding
virtual reality and let me say this
Larry because I think you're gonna get a
kick out of this because if you think
emojis is crazy let me tell you what
about to tell you 12 years from today
when we're doing this interview as we're
gonna have a long relationship as you
said we're gonna be doing it it's gonna
feel like it's happening just like right
now except one thing we're both going to
be sitting at home about an industry
that's slowing down or dying I think
television advertising is in deep crap
business leader we should be paying more
attention to I think Jeff Bezos who runs
Amazon is the single best entrepreneur
of this century including Steve Jobs he
went into the newspaper business cuz
he's smart you know what he did there
Larry he went into the brand business he
bought that brand Washington Post for
nothing and now he's gonna deploy it in
a different platform like the Kindle
what's the best success story ever heard
you know it's funny that's a great
question I am I'm very under educated on
the entrepreneurs and successful people
in the world
my favorite success story is my dad he
came here with nothing yeah zero good
example I live in a studio apartment a
quarter of the size of this studio
yeah he's young he's 62 it's only 20
years old 22 years old me they'll work
on them on fire part of the world that
is exploding in business and commerce
I'm very intrigued by Africa
I think Africa is emerging they've got
cell phones then at scale I think that's
gonna be the place everyone's gonna
focus the next decade young entrepreneur
who's impressing you I think Mark
Zuckerberg is gonna take that throne
from Jeff Bezos and I think he's grossly
grossly underestimated and in parallel
Evan Spiegel of snapchat has surprised
me sundar he's 25 I think the way he's
navigated that business with all the
pressure of the whole world looking kids
get this in garages what a little
where does this come from this comes I
don't think it's genius I think that
they're lucky that the internet came
along and allowed them to do it earlier
the Internet is such scale Larry where
is the internet bottom in the in the
ocean and the sky I mean you know the
the Internet is basically our lives I
actually think the Internet is more our
life than this is this is where people
spend their time attention is the asset
and the Internet owns it
Gary Vaynerchuk in ten years uh hustling
owning the Jets now not yet my behavior
doesn't map to owning the Jets in ten
years my behavior Maps toning the Jets
in 30 a lot of social media questions
arena brainy on Facebook when do you
know you're ready to start a business if
you're asking that question you're
probably not ready Larry I believe a
pure-bred entrepreneur suffocates in the
notion of doing anything but running
their own business at chief chipper on
Twitter what was your favorite baseball
card as a kid 1990 lease Frank Thomas
rookie card me and my friend Brandon
adored that card just saw Frank couple
leaves he's a real player he was a real
player the whole thing yep Bruce
McKellen on the Larry King now blog do
you get political at all what are your
thoughts on people from the private
sector Donald Trump I don't tend to get
political mainly because I voted both
party lines already at this young of an
age multiple times I really I'm quite
practical about politics I wait -
there's a decision and I make the
decision that I think is best in the
current situation at breakdance cape on
Twitter what's more what's more
investable a digital company with
millions of users and no profits or one
with a few users and millions in profit
both is true but if there's real growth
at no profit with millions of users
that's the one that you want to run
because the upside is so great at
Twitter had that right yeah and look I I
was an early investor in Twitter Twitter
isn't bad is it it's not bad I mean by
the way I made a crapload of money Larry
like the people who invested in Twitter
before when public made a fortune
Twitter's
is that it needs to hold on to the
attention of its users mr. Liu on
Facebook ass in the age of digital media
how do you suggest someone maintain a
solid print audience by making sure a
they are building a digital audience and
by be trying to find something clever
that the print product can deliver that
the digital product cannot and also this
Larry holding your breath I mean the
user is dying off and when I say dying I
don't mean literally dying I mean we are
watching 40 50 60 70 80 year olds shift
into digital consumption but if print is
dying
why does a Carlos Slim invest in the New
York Times because he wants to use that
to push his propaganda he's got a
vehicle yeah as Jeff Bezos of course
Larry that's the real answer you know it
yeah at kjm 10:16 on twitter how would
you suggest one avoids running their
social media outlets without making it
feel like spam by not being spam Larry
this pisses me off all the time people
like how do I be less Celie
be less le provide people actual value
like if you don't want your social media
to feel spammy why don't you talk about
putting out content and acting like a
media company instead of acting like a
salesperson John Crabtree on the Larry
King now blog do you see any new apps
emerging as game changes in the next few
years you know I'm very like I mentioned
I'm very hot on musically I also think
anchor this audio app is quite
interesting think of its think of it as
a voice Twitter so you instead of
tweeting
you're doing it by voice so you
literally put the phone to yourself and
say you know today I'm thinking and
quite interesting it's very very early
but I'm keeping a very keen eye on it
who invents these things youngsters a
lot of times who don't know any better
you know what I would tell you and I
think you'll this will make sense to you
I look at it very similar to music
genres I think of it as like The Clash
and Kurt Cobain and Run DMC I think it's
people who come up they don't see what
they want and they create it at soul man
Schofield do you think you'll ever
retire or
you enjoy working too much I look I
think when I'm sitting here with you and
I know all the context I know about you
and all the fact they pretty much of
interview and anybody who's important in
the last 50 goddamn years the thing that
most excites me is that you're sitting
right here right now and interviewing me
I have no interest in doing anything
other that to me is the most interesting
thing that's happening in this room
right now is that while I'm doing this
interview the parallel part of my brain
is saying damn this is the guy I'm doing
this this is exactly what I'm gonna be
doing are you married
I am you have children I do what how
older children 6 and 3 boy and a girl
girl boy all right how do you your
thoughts on your ability and business to
raising a family do you use the
principles that I do I do I think I
think first of all minam I'm an eqh are
driven CEO I think I win not on my IQ
but on my emotional intelligence I think
that I'm very in tune to people's
feelings I try to reverse-engineer what
they're about for example I have no
interest in my kids being anything but
who they are
my mom gifted with me gifted me by
parenting me to my strengths if my kids
are artists or want to be in the
nonprofit sector I climb mountains I'm
all-in I want them to do them the one
line in the sand I have is no
eighth-place trophies
Lizzie knows and now I'm looking at the
camera because I wanted to see my eyes
again no 8th place trophies life is
about winning and losing it's binary
right so as long as my kids know that I
don't care what they do they don't need
to make money they don't need to be
entrepreneurs but to win there's a real
market to be a great artist to be great
at helping other people you have to be
great at it if your wife get involved in
your business no we have a very strong
line in the sand my parents had that our
parents had that for the most part so I
think we're just kind of acting on what
we saw behaviorally we don't I don't
like I don't like look when you're the
CEO of a cup when you're the top dog
you're only in the negative issues
business I'm a firefighter
all I'm dealing with is headaches what's
going to happen right now I'm going to
step out of here and look at my phone
there's me seven things I have to deal
with that isn't a fun thing to deal with
so to come home and pour that on my wife
isn't interesting I don't have anything
positive to
on a micro-level it's all negative it's
the macro-level that's awesome now your
incredible great indeed on you near the
first of many meeting thank you my
friend
[Music]